let's go to our next caller at the
six-30 area code caller from six-30 go
ahead
hey David what's going on how you doing
who's this remember when I called you uh
two months ago or three months ago about
you know going on whether you go on draw
or obese podcast I do vaguely remember
that yeah
did you see the podcast with well this
is not gonna be my main question but did
you see the podcast with Jimmy coracle
kolinsky I saw about 90 seconds of each
do that again I saw about a minute and a
half of each of those I watched both
they were pretty fantastic I would love
to see you and Sam cedar go on one day
I'm glad to go on any time by by all
means yeah okay now moving on now these
one two main questions now my main
question of you know you know
conservative and comedian of steven
crowder right I'm familiar with him yeah
yeah so the reason why I brought him
love was because two weeks ago he he got
suspended from Twitter for a week over
because of a video that he posted where
an intern of his crash had an LGBTQ
event in Texas and after he posted it
hours later YouTube deleted the video
and Twitter decided to suspend his
account for a week and after after that
like he eventually uh got his Twitter
account back and he was able to post the
video but he had to blur out some of the
stuff okay but like an insurance of is
like when he crashing he literally
dressed up as a computer but I don't
know what they were trying to do I think
it was just for comedy but I mean I do
go through the whole story but I don't
want to like waste your time so my
question to you is like what are your
thoughts on him getting suspended on
Twitter for a week
listen I don't know anything about this
story and I of course I have no way of
knowing if it's as you describe it or if
there's key pieces of information
missing here's my so my personal view is
my personal view is I am close to a free
speech absolutist in that anything short
of an of an incitement to violence or
criminality like speech which would
include a video that
is criminal in some way I believe should
just sort of be allowed to exist at the
same time I have to recognize the right
of companies like Google which owns
YouTube and Twitter to establish and
enforce Terms of Service even if I
disagree with them and my sort of power
as a consumer is to choose not to use
those platforms if I feel like their
Terms of Service don't agree with with
what I think they should be here's the
thing David the thing it's the video
this was not violent it was just
crashing in at a Nevada just just for
joking comedy look I don't I don't agree
with Crowder on a lot of topics I think
he's just he's overall and an obnoxious
human being okay but overall I don't
think he should be he should not be
banned on Twitter I've seen some of his
videos and I agree with him on John's
and abortion but overall I don't think
he should have been suspended from
Twitter over that that video okay but
you do recognize Twitter's right to have
the Terms of Service that they want to
and to suspend users at their discretion
right you respect that right of a
private company no I respect their
rights I mean they do whatever they want
but I'm just saying overall like I mean
I know I am just any Crowder but you are
I'm just trying to like I'm just trying
to like I'm just trying to defend both
sides and really pretended like I
support like my opposition's right to do
whatever they want even though I don't
agree with them okay all right very good
well glad you made that point we know
you're defending both sides and I'm not
familiar with the story but at least
I've been able to explain my view
generally speaking on on this issue